période la solidarité de rigueur cet
exemple en france avec l'association
aviation sans frontières parrainé par
l'astronaute thomas pesquet elle s'est
engagée à faciliter les transports
urgents des personnels de santé de
matériel médical leur plateforme à est
lancée aujourd'hui lé détail c'est avec
cyrielle boétie mobiliser l'ensemble des
moyens aéronautiques privé c'est la
mission que s'est fixée l'équipe
d'aviation sans frontières à l'aide
d'une plateforme
cette organisation non gouvernementale
met en relation les pilotes
professionnels et les propriétaires
d'avions avec le personnel hospitalier
lo ng s'appuie sur les avions d'affaires
grâce à sa petite taille ce type
d'appareil est idéal puisqu'il est
capable de se poser n'importe où en
france où près de 500 aérodrome existent
ces avions peuvent ainsi se poser à
moins de 40 minutes de chaque structure
hospitalière
ce qui permet de faire gagner un temps
précieux aux équipes soignantes qui ont
besoin de se rendre rapidement
disponibles en renfort la nuit dernière
est partie un autocar avec 30 personnels
à bord pour faire un bordeaux strasbourg
voilà c'est juste impensable ça les
fatigue c'est dangereux
là on les prend dans de très bonnes
conditions on a déjà commencé on dispose
à peu près d'une quarantaine d'avions de
6 à 50 places
eh bien on est devenus malheureusement
la première compagnie opérationnel en
france aujourd'hui alors que la
plateforme doit ouvrir dans les
prochains jours certaines villes de
france telles que marseille toulon ou
encore mulhouse ont déjà pu bénéficier
des services de cette ong aviation sans
frontières ne se limite pas au transport
de personnels soignants puisque
l'association permet également
d'acheminer du matériel médical avec
l'appui du ministère des transports
l'association s'est mise en relation
avec les professionnels qui peuvent
aider à mettre sur pied ces opérations
notamment l'aviation civile le groupe
total a également aidé les ong en
offrant une grande partie du carburant
utilisé par les avions ce qui leur
permet de proposer ce transport gratuit
pour les soignants l'association
humanitaire doit malgré tout faire appel
aux dons afin de continuer ses
opérations
l'astronaute thomas pesquet parent
d'aviation sans frontières a d'ailleurs
lancé un appel au volontariat pour
maintenir ce genre d'initiative